aujourd'hui tout le monde à 111,06 vous
même ce 07 mais il ya encore quelques
années les postes fixes étaient la norme
et il y à 25 ans chamboulement au 18
octobre 1996 à 23 heures précises les
numéros de téléphone vont changer en
france ils passeront à dix chiffres il
s'agit de prendre en compte le nombre de
communications toujours croissant au
milieu des années 90 la france compte 32
millions d'abonnés au bout du fil et les
demandes explosent alors pour avoir plus
de numéros des préfixes téléphoniques
sont mises en place 0 1 pour paris et sa
région 03 pour l'est etc cinq
indicateurs selon la région les numéros
passe donc de 8 à 10 chiffres source
d'angoissé pour certains peut-être un
petit peu
parce que les cinq régions jeu pas très
bien je m'en fiche
l'état met alors en place des campagnes
publicitaires
rappelez vous madame lieu le 18 octobre
ces deux chiffres en tête et 10 chiffres
en tout et les journalistes au site ne
lésinez pas sur les moyens pour rassurer
les français en faisant appel à un
neurologue largement assez de place dans
la tête pour stocker ces chiffres et
bien d'autres choses ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il peut y avoir des petits
confusion france télécom faisait
carrément des campagnes d'information
dans les écoles vous avez trop de
chiffres et puis là on va pouvoir mettre
des autres dans le petit tu d'ouest on a
le numéro 4 5 pourquoi va commencer ton
numéro maintenant
03/06
après toutes ces préparations s'est mise
en condition le 18 octobre
22h59 le show commence ambiance compte à
rebours
est lentement le rideau soleil sur une
france en train de basculer de huit à
dix chiffres
le lendemain dans les rues les français
n'étaient pas encore au point pour paris
et si vous devez appeler à paris est ce
que vous savez ce que vous devez faire
de 0,4 je crois paris le 04 une fable un
nom bien combien de jeunes en france
4 5 10 ans
non j'ai pas du tout en fait ce passage
à dix chiffres devaient permettre
d'avoir 470 millions de nouveaux numéros
mais au final la croissance des
téléphones portables a tout bousculé et
en 2010 les 06 ont laissé leur place au
[Musique]